my first trip was in August of 2003, I was really delighted,
I really wanted to work
in Haiti because I knew the program here
was about
health care broadly
including HIV and TB.
So they come in first and they get weighed and
their blood pressure taken over here on the right hand side
it's pretty much the best job in the world, I
can't imagine
I would enjoy anything
as much as I like being a doctor.
And the complaints are pretty
you know pretty varied from very very sick people
who come like really
we call it carried in on a stretcher
they get carried in from home
to coughs and colds
to children is diarrhea, malaria, we have an awful lot of
gastritis, high blood pressure, so people
just line up to get seen
and they get seen one after another
and then we just finish when the last patient has been seen.
You know one day I had a little girl
who was about eight
die of malnutrition
like an eight-year-old dying of starvation
you know like honesty most people that I know
in the US or in Ireland don't actually
know anyone whose child has died.
I can't actually, I can't sleep at night
you know, because of the things that I see.
Like I've seen more children dying in my arms than
most people have ever experienced in their whole lives
and this is just everyday stuff. We only see the
half of it.
You know it's not even a question of what keeps
me here it's like
what keeps me there, like why do I go back to
Boston, I'm not really sure.
But you know, that's part of my family are there
and that's where the connection is with
the university and that's the academic
part
There is just so much work here to do that I just
find it so compelling
I just can't not do it.